Elf happens. Elf becomes this massive
hit, by the way. Old school.
The same, right? But you.
Well, yeah. And so then.
It's lining up.
Night at the Roxbury.
Yeah. One of my honest all time
favorite movies just from.
That's where you start to understand
like the opportunities to come from SNL
based off of their most popular
sketches, could go and springboard into
films.
They were great to kind of just get your
feet wet, but then.
Super fortunate in that the first three
movies after I leave the show are Old
school, Elf, and Anchorman.
Yeah, Bang, bang, bang.
It kind of lined up with the world of
success from the show versus the world
of success. Like with the movies,
after, there's a significant change of
course in attention.
How did you handle that? Because you're
not a you're not a guy that loves the
world of pap, pap, pap, pap, all this
shit. How did you handle.
Unlike you. You love it. What the f***
does that mean? You love it. What does
that mean? Oh, pop, pop, pop.
What does that mean?
You love. You love the lights.
What is that? What are you saying?
Yeah.
What do you mean? Yeah? What is that?
No, I. Because my hobby, I'm a paparazzi
when I have downtime. Okay.
And I love following you around.
No, you don't. You don't follow me.
You always give us great shots.
No.
Thank you.
No, the paparazzi community.
You don't. You're not a fucking
paparazzi, so stop it.
All right.
Maybe one day they'll let me in.
How did you handle it? I didn't really.
There was.
I do remember walking around New York.
After the opening weekend of Elf.
And that was the real first time where.
My wife and I are walking around and
people are following us around.
And that was kind of.
Yeah, a little exciting in a weird way
and a little alarming.
Was like, Why is this guy walking?
Someone's on the other side of the
sidewalk walking the same speed as I
am? That's a weird feeling.
What are they doing? And then why is he
dressing all black?
And then why is he holding a big
camera? What is.
He doing? Why did he take a picture of
me?
Who's he photographed?
You've never you've never really bought
into the idea of.
Of the fame, though. That's not.
That's not you. You love the job.
You do the job. But you never bought
into. I'm famous.
I'm Will Ferrell. And here I am.
Like, that's not your cup of tea and
you're very frugal.
You're a cheap ass.
You're a f***ing cheap ass.
You don't spend any of your money.
How much do you have saved?
Huh? How much do you f***ing have
saved? Jesus Christ.
I've never seen anybody save more of it
in my goddamn life.
It's nothing you don't spend a f***ing.
Have you looked into my financials?
No. You don't spend f***ing money.
You don't care. You still got your
BlackBerry.
I wish.
You had it,
for a long.
Crumbled to to dust that BlackBerry,
though.
Oh.
Don't you miss it?
No.
The textured keyboard.
Just the sensation of the.
Clack, clack, clack, clack.
Oh, brick breaker.
Relax. The little brick breaker.
Yeah.
Why?
Why have you not truly bought into the
higher side? What keeps you grounded?
What keeps you in the humble thinking
space?
I, um.
Because I.
I grew up a little bit around it.
Enough to see, you know, like I was
saying, my dad was a working musician,
and he lived hand-to-mouth.
You know, there'd be he'd be playing
gigs for.
Six months at the, you know, an Italian
restaurant down the street.
And then he'd come home and be like,
well. Gotta find a new place to play.
I'm like, What happened? Like nothing
happened. They.
They love me. And they said they're
just going into a new, new direction.
So we had to find a new place, new you
know, it was.
It was all just was like, this is boy,
this is tough. And and I would go and
listen to him play and I thought, I
don't get it. He sounds he's as good a
musician as anyone's I've ever heard.
But. Why isn't, you know, the Hollywood
thing of someone walking into a
restaurant and discovering someone like
signing to a record contract?
Oh, that doesn't exist.
And so I just always had that in the
back of my mind that it's, you know.
I've just never taken any of it for
granted, ever.